[Music]
would you take a class
from an anti-cop ass during a traffic
stop in la county a woman claiming to be
a teacher
unleashed a tirade on a latino deputy
the speed limit is 40 and i was going 38
so why are you harassing you are correct
i pulled you over because you're a
murderer yes i started to record because
you can't be it
you can't be on your cell phone while
you're driving the pictured me it made
me think you were going to murder me
okay i'm sorry you feel that way well
you're that's not just a feeling you're
a murderer
i'm perfectly legal and i'm a teacher
so there congratulations you're a
murderer
would say hold that still for me okay
murderer
so she's a teacher i wonder what subject
she teaches like how to ask to speak to
the manager
i mean imagine getting dinner with that
later you know she probably sends back
the appetizer before even ordering it
it gets worse he's only citing you for
using your cell phone while you're
driving that's it there you go ma'am
sign inside the ribbon for him being a
mexican racist
what is that name yes it's under
citation man here you go mexican racist
you're always going to be a mexican
you'll never be white you know that
right
oh my god something tells me this woman
has had to press one for english just
once too often
yeah nothing gets you out of a traffic
ticker ticket faster than some bonus
racism
to think of all the times i just tried
to show some cleavage
meanwhile a professor at cypress college
in southern cal
is on leave after berating a student who
called police
think cops are heroes and they have to
have a difficult job but we have to have
all of my life oh i i'm not i mean
i'd say a good majority of them you have
bad people in every business and every
part yeah wait police officers have
committed atrocious crimes and have
gotten away with it and have never been
convicted of any of it
what do we call when we're in trouble
when someone has a knife or a gun
[Music]
why wouldn't you call the police i don't
trust them what would you call
time to go okay
we have to go so trouble with a knife or
gun
sounds like a job for a social worker
turns out she's not the only faculty
against the force a growing number of
professors and students across the
country have pledged support to the
cops off-campus coalition an
organization aimed at removing all
police from campus they're demanding
zero police presence on may 25th which
sounds like a pretty good day to steal a
professor's vespa
[Laughter]
but without campus police where would
they report their hate crime hoaxes
on the upside the gofundme that was set
up for the officer suspended for mocking
lebron james has skyrocketed to over 400
grand that's nearly a buck for every
time lebron fakes getting fouled
that's funny because i don't know what i
just said i know nothing about
basketball that was written for me
because i'm stupid on sports
emily that cop was a saint right
yes yes we know my temper
this is what's so insane to me that
these cops endure
this unrelenting verbal abuse
that was a nauseating encounter and yet
through it all we expect them to not
only exercise restraint but also
exhibit that polite decorum that he did
and they're also getting physically
attacked and
ambushed and killed and we wonder why
death by suicide for them is twice as
much as dying in the line of fire i mean
these guys are being subjected
to an incredible incredible assault at
all levels and that trend is horrifying
yet the left seems to celebrate it
i find it sickening and i think what
what is additionally and maybe more
devastating than the community vilifying
them from the left is the fact that
they're not getting any public support
whatsoever
by the democrat public elected officials
right they're not getting anyone
that is saying these that is stating
public messages of support so that they
know
that someone else has their back these
guys are being isolated
and um it's really troubling no it is
you know
senator it is it this this current
climate of anti-police sentiment
it's like energizing people even more to
openly
you know crap on cops i mean she she
thought that she was gonna get famous
like
i'm gonna record this cop while he's
doing absolutely nothing
but just being polite but she feels like
this is the right time to do it you know
well and this is one of the reasons
people wanting to stand
up and support police like they
the gofundme that has just taken off so
this is the american people voting with
their dollar to say
we stand with our cops of course
there are going to every once in a while
be someone
who is not within the code of conduct
but by and large the overwhelming
majority and god bless these men and
women every single day
for the jobs that they are doing and for
what they have to endure
is they do those jobs yeah you know
tyrus what was great was he didn't use
any intersectional language
but he was awesome like i mean you know
the thing i'm like
like people forget that that they have
to put up with
idiots every day and that was a true
idiot yeah and you know
i think even harder for him is that i'm
not 100 i'm pretty sure she was hispanic
too and sometimes the word and i said it
before racism is not just for whites
anymore
being called basically she was calling
him a uncle tom and
mexican right that she was looking for
right but this trend
of of making it fashionable to resist
arrest
or to struggle with police officers
leads down a road that ends up bad for a
lot of people
yeah she's not rosa parks in that moment
and she's
she's borderline and criminal and she
couldn't accept her consequences and
this is the last
individual that should be teaching
children anything
just based off her comments and her lack
of
education that when she was frustrated
and she was got called on the phone the
only thing she could do was call names
and make racist comments about somebody
that's in our classroom
that's teaching our kids to problem
solve imagine she is with okay same
thing with the other professor
this is who's educating our kids they're
setting precedence because they're not
affected
she got away with it she probably could
have spit on him and he
got away with it but that cop that the
the bad cop everybody talks about you
pull that with him
it's not gonna end that way so why put
yourself in that situation yeah
for the one out of every 200 cops that
not gonna take that
why would you incite that yeah and then
why would you polarize it no one should
be applauding her
yeah be ashamed of herself yeah you know
uh kat
uh i have a feeling that after all this
happens she's now gonna become the
victim
she tried to like so she tried to film
it and then she got filmed
and now she's gonna say like now i'm
getting death threats after she she was
calling him a murderer
that's my prediction right yeah cause
it's totally normal when you're you know
mildly inconvenienced to just call that
person a murderer right
same thing i do when i go out to eat
they're out of clam chowder
you murder her you murderer it's awful
and there really are real things that
need to be done criminal justice reform
rise police reform wise
nobody with half a brain could think
that means there is going to be no
law enforcement agency you're going to
have laws you have to have law
enforcement and the more ridiculous this
gets
the further we get away from actually
making the changes that need to be made
because yeah we need police we need a
law enforcement agency
i'm in the process of getting murdered i
am definitely calling the cops
before i call the therapist therapist is
for later
especially if the therapist is trying to
kill you
all sessions are on zoom now
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else